Ich glaube, er hat zumindest einen medizinhistorischen
Hintergrund. Nicht historisch, einen medizinischen
Hintergrund. Er hat eine medizinische
Historie. Ja, genau.
So wie...
Na, wo wollte ich gerade hin?
Hab ich vergessen. Toll.
Langhafte Politik.
Ich würde für diesen Podcast schon so lange
machen, dass ich das Pad, in dem wir
die Notizen regelmäßig führen,
seitdem schon dreimal umbenannt hat.
Jetzt heißt es Hedge-Doc.
In der URL heißt es noch
Codimd. War das nicht mal Hack-MD?
Hack-MD. Aber wir haben sogar vor Hack-MD
angefangen, oder? Wir haben vor Hack-MD angefangen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch zum fünfjährigen
Podcast-Jubiläum. Ich gratuliere.
Wir haben wirklich seit wenigen Tagen,
seit zwei Wochen, fünf Jahre,
sind wir fünf Jahre alt.
Also nicht mehr, wir haben ja früher immer die Witze gemacht,
dass wir in den Folgen unser Alter bemessen haben,
sprich, wir sind jetzt volljährig, wir dürfen wählen
und so weiter. Ja, wir gehen langsam
aufs Rentenalter zu mit unseren Folgenzahlen.
Autsch. Wir haben ja einen Podcast
mit Life Crisis. Wenn wir nach echtem Alter
gehen, dann kommen wir bald in die Schule.
Oh ja.
Also literally nach alt.
Wenn ich mir unsere Notes angucke, scheinen wir aber das
Schreiben eher so ein bisschen zu verlernen.
Ich finde es schön,
dass wir niemals Leuten gezeigt haben,
wie gepflegt unsere Shownotes
sind, bevor sie in den Podcast kommen.
Du möchtest ja auch nicht wissen, wie die Wurst gemacht wird.
Genau, das ist wirklich der Sausage-Effekt.
Das willst du nicht wissen. Übrigens, spielst du eigentlich
Wordle? Ne, ich bin in der
Kontrollgruppe.
Ah.
Dann muss ich dir jetzt unbedingt zeigen.
Wir können ein Spiel spielen.
Ich zeige dir bunte
Karos und du sagst mir, ist das ein
Wordle oder ist das irgendwas anderes?
Ist das wie
so ein Rohrschachtest?
Ein Rohr-Wordle-Test?
Ein Wordle-Test, also pass auf.
Zumindest gibt es auf Twitter dieses schöne
Hashtag
irgendwas anderes und dann Sachen, die man aus
diesen gleichen
nervigen Karo-Grafiken
zusammenbauen kann. Und ich muss sagen,
ich habe ein paar Spieleideen, wenn ich die so sehe.
Manche von den Dingern sehen so ein bisschen aus
wie ein
Roguelike, weißt du?
Oh ja.
Generell wie ein
Top-Down-2D-Spiel,
wo es mehr um das Gameplay
ist, die Grafik geht.
Vieles davon sind Roguelike,
aber es muss kein Roguelike sein.
ist es eigentlich ein Roguelike
oder ein Roguelite?
Oh, da habe ich mich neulich mit Diamanten drüber gestritten.
Ich würde sagen, es ist ein Roguelike, weil es wie ein
Rogue ist. Aber es gibt auch den Begriff Roguelite,
was irgendwie Anlehnung an das
Original Rogue ist, aber nur so
ein bisschen in die Richtung geht.
Ich suche gerade, und ein Spiel,
was schön ist, ist...
Sorry, jetzt habe ich dich unterbrochen.
Mehr Gedanken gab es da nicht.
Es gibt bloß einen Unterschied zwischen Roguelike und Roguelite,
habe ich gelernt.
Und zwar?
Das ist der Unterschied. Das eine ist
wie Rogue, das andere ist wie Rogue...
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Don't put me on the spotlight.
Aber ein Spiel, was tatsächlich schon genauso funktioniert
wie diese Wordle-Grafiken, ist
dieses Twitter-Tetris.
Twitter-Tetris?
Ich such's gerade raus, ich folge dem sogar.
Ja, Tetris auf Twitter und dem
folge ich.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, wie der...
wenn du es dann suchst, ich habe es ständig in meiner Timeline,
aber wenn du es dann suchst, findest du es nicht.
Ich muss aber eventuell nur ein bisschen scrollen.
Hier ist es bereits. Guck es dir an.
Emoji-Tetra.
Die posten einfach jeden Tag,
oder sie posten einmal pro Stunde oder sowas Tetris.
Und wenn ein neues Spiel losgeht, ist es ein neues Theme.
Diesmal sind es Kleidungsstücke-Emojis.
Und da oben kommt ein neuer Block rein.
Und dann ist das...
Sie posten quasi ein Tetris-Board zu einem Timestamp.
Genau. Und dann ist das ein Poll.
mit links, rechts, rotieren oder runter.
Und dann musste es dann auf Twitter abstimmen,
wie dieses Spiel Twitter gemeinsam.
Twitter-Plays Tetris.
Genau.
Erinnerst du dich noch an diese Twitch-Plays irgendwas,
Sachen, die mal eine Zeit lang populär waren?
Wo jemand zum Beispiel einen Pokémon-Emulator
an Twitch gehangen hat und den Input aus dem Chat genommen hat.
Aber dann war das teilweise, es gab Unterschiede.
Es gab die Variante, wo der Chat abgestimmt hat
und es wurde jeden Timestamp, also jede Sekunde
oder jede drei Sekunden oder irgendwas,
eine Aktion durchgeführt.
Und das, was dem Chat am meisten gesagt wurde, wurde genommen.
Oder es wurde einfach per Zufall immer das erste,
wo der Input ankam, genommen, was vom Chat akzeptiert wurde.
Alles wurde gespammt an den Emulator.
Und das, was vom Emulator akzeptiert wurde,
war einfach das, was genommen wurde.
Und irgendwie haben sich die Leute geschafft,
nicht nur Pokémon durchzuspielen.
Die haben auch Dark Souls durchgespielt.
Ein Spiel, was fucking notoriously hard ist,
wenn du es alleine spielst.
Aber die haben es irgendwie geschafft, so zu spielen.
Sie haben nebenbei gleichzeitig auch noch Shakespeare geschrieben.
Ich komme da immer noch nicht an.
Aber es gibt diesen Dude,
der Dark Souls mit
mit dem Lenkrad
gespielt hat, durchgespielt hat,
dann gibt es diesen Dude, der Dark Souls
überhaupt, da bin ich total raus.
So ein Souls-like, das kannst du deinen Kollegen Julius mal fragen.
Ein Souls-like?
Aber ist das nicht irgendein 3D-Spiel?
Ja, ja, ja.
So ein Ego-Shooter-Spiel oder sowas?
Nee, es ist ein Rollenspiel.
Ist das so eins, wo man immer so eine
Pseudo-3D-Szene hat, wo man durchläuft?
Nee, nee, es ist schon ein Voll-3D-Spiel.
Ein modernes Voll-3D-Spiel.
aber was halt scheiß schwer ist, weil es darauf ausgelegt ist
dass du halt die ganze Zeit stirbst
ach so, ach das ist das mit dem Ritter
wo dann plötzlich irgendwo ein Monster steht und dann rennt der Typ
wieder weg, das mit dem Ritter wo plötzlich
ein Monster steht
wow, sorry, das sind so
das sind so kurze GIFs, die bei mir irgendwie
wieder in der Erinnerung
vorkommen, die mal an mir vorbeigescrollt
sind auf Twitter, frag mal Julius, Julius spielt
sehr gerne Souls-Likes
Souls-Likes, aber es ist doch so ein
Schockerspiel oder so ein
Gruselspiel, oder? Es ist ein bisschen
düster, aber es ist kein Gruselspiel.
Es ist kein Horrorspiel oder so.
Da ist Doom schlimmer.
Wollte gerade sagen.
Aber die Leute haben das halt gespielt und es gibt einen Typen,
der hat das auf den fucking
Donkey Kong
Trommeln gespielt gehabt und hat das irgendwie
geschafft. Und dann gab es noch
ähnlichen, auch so, das ist relativ aktuell,
Sekiro. Ich bin kein
Fan von solchen Spielen. Also ich schaue gerne
Leuten zu, die sowas spielen. In letzter Zeit tatsächlich
Julius.
wir zusammen Demon's Souls spielen.
Bzw. er spielt das.
Zwei andere schauen zu.
Ich spiele jetzt mal wieder eine Runde.
Wer möchte mir zu...
Naja, wir machen das direkt bei mir.
Ach, sehr geil.
Ich dachte, ihr habt da so eine private,
kleine Twitch-Session.
Nee, nee, das finde ich wieder langweiliger.
Ich finde es gut.
Aber vor allem, also Demon's Souls ist sehr witzig,
weil das Spiel hat wirklich einfach nur einen Bug
aneinandergereitet an den anderen.
Beziehungsweise nicht einen Bug.
Die haben halt dämliche Features.
Du musstest speedrunnen quasi,
damit es funktioniert, oder wie?
Nicht unbedingt.
Es ist einfach ein witziges Spiel.
Die Story gibt es nicht viel.
Es ist cool gemacht.
Ich verstehe mittlerweile den Anreiz solcher Spiele,
dass man solche unsäglich schweren
Bosskämpfe besteht.
Aber
ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen von einem Typen,
der Sekiro, was auch so ein Spiel ist, was in die Richtung geht,
spielt komplett blindfolded.
Der Typ hat einfach ein Blindfold auf
und spielt dieses Spiel komplett durch.
Weil er einfach das schon so häufig gemacht hat.
Der hat es einfach quasi im Kopf.
der weiß, was er bei den Bosskämpfen machen muss,
der weiß, welches Timing er ausweichen muss,
der spielt das ausschließlich
durch Audio-Feedback.
I don't get it.
Das ist so...
Nee, nee, nee.
Das ist nicht meine Welt von Spiel.
Und dann spiele ich das auch noch so.
Aber Wirtle spielst du auch nicht, sagst du?
Nee, ich spiele andere Sachen.
Ich musste bloß neulich an dich denken, weil das Wort, was rauskam vor ein paar Tagen,
war tatsächlich Moist.
Schön, dass du dabei an mich denken musst.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ah, da war irgendwas mit
Kira, dem würden sich jetzt die Zehnegel
hochrollen. Super.
Aber bleib du mal ruhig in der Kontrollgruppe,
das ist schon okay. Ich bleib bei meinem Placeable.
Placeable.
Gibt's das wirklich eigentlich? Hat das irgendjemand gehostet?
Ich meine, es ist in dem
XKCD genannt worden,
2576, also der
nicht ganz aktuellste, aber der fast aktuellste.
Das ist aber falsch geschrieben. Ach nee, das heißt Placeable.
Placeable, hier.
Oh nein, das hat...
Oh Gott, tatsächlich
Tage alt.
Das ist halt das Technik,
wie heißt er,
Randall Monroe schreibt irgendwas
und der kann sich einfach Dinge
in Existence wünschen.
Wenn Randall Monroe irgendwas haben möchte,
erwähnt das am Rande von einem Comic.
Ich glaube, so muss ich das anfühlen, wenn man ein Gott ist.
Man denkt an etwas und das wird Realität.
Der kann literally, ja,
to wish it into existence.
Da gab es so eine,
ich verlinke mal den
XKCD mit den Show Notes,
2, 5, 7, 6
Uch, jetzt drückt die ein bisschen ab
Es gab mal so eine
Es gibt immer noch so eine coole Rasse in der D&D-Welt
Ich vergesse immer wieder, wie die heißen
Das waren so witzige Fischmenschen
Aber die hatten das
Blubblub
Das ist, denke ich, ein Carpador aus Pokémon
It's a trap
Kannst du gerade Admiral Ackbar
als Carpador bezeichnen
Das ist doch auch so ein Fischmensch, oder?
Autsch
sie heißen literally irgendwas mit Kalamari.
Sie heißen Mon Calamari in Star Wars.
Nein.
Sie heißen Kalamari irgendwas.
Doch.
Oh Gott.
Aber anyway, weiter.
Nee, diese Fischmenschen, deren Namen ich immer wieder vergesse,
die hatten so eine witzige Fähigkeit als Volk an sich,
dass wenn die alle an was geglaubt haben,
dann ist das Realität geworden.
Sprich, wenn du die halt überzeugst in deiner D&D-Welt,
dass der Leuchtturm ein Monster ist, der
tagsüber einfach wandern geht, dann
ist das plötzlich so, weil die das
alle glauben.
Hier, die heißen Mon Calamari.
Die heißen doch nicht wirklich fucking Calamari.
Doch, die heißen Calamari.
Oh je.
Ja, also
Star Wars ist relativ inkonsistent
in sich selbst.
But Mon Calamari were a bipedal
amphibious species with high-domed heads,
webbed hands and large goggle-like eyes.
Yep.
Bei denen frage ich mich eigentlich, wenn der den ganzen Tag auf der Brücke sitzt von so einem Cruiser,
die sind ja eigentlich unter Wasser Lebewesen,
müssen die sich regelmäßig irgendwie selber die Augen mit Wasser einsprühen,
dass die nicht austrocknen oder sowas?
Weil die müssten doch eigentlich total trockene Haut kriegen, oder?
Ja, ist bestimmt wie so ein Gungan.
Die haben ja dasselbe Problem.
Ja.
Wenn Darth Jar Jar, das ist meine Lieblings-Star-Wars-Fan-Therie immer noch,
das passt richtig gut ins Konzept.
Du hast doch bis zum Schluss nicht gedacht, dass der Kanzler irgendwie ein Sith ist
und der Jar Jar hat voll mitgespielt.
Und Jar Jar ist halt der Ultrasith und der steuert halt nicht nur Darth Sidious, sondern halt literally alle in den ersten zwei Episoden.
Und der hat alles in der Hand und das macht ihn zu einem richtig mächtigen Hintergrundcharakter.
Das macht irgendwie Sinn.
Darth Jar Jar, Mann. Darth Jar Jar.
Okay, wir haben es. Ich glaube, wir haben es. Ja, ich glaube es jetzt auch.
Oh Mann.
Ja, was ist denn sonst noch in letzter Zeit passiert?
Ist mal wieder irgendwas auf
NPM passiert?
Das kam auch ein Fuck-up.
Irgendwas haben wir mit NPM.
Irgendwas war noch nicht mit NPM.
Ich habe einen hübschen neuen NPM-Sticker, den habe ich leider gerade noch nicht auf dem MacBook-Leber,
der liegt bei mir noch daheim rum.
Wieso würdest du dir einen NPM-Sticker auf deinem MacBook nehmen?
Weil der nicht NPM steht, sondern Pip, aber in der NPM-Font.
Ah, du hast dir diese Fake-Dinger bestellt.
Ich finde die so toll.
Das Wim-Logo muss das V halt dann, wie es Code weitergeht.
Oder das Debian-Logo,
und dann eben steht Ubuntu.
I love it.
Kann ich den haben?
Welchen?
Diesen VS Code Wim?
Mache ich dem mit?
Geil.
Mir passt der auch noch richtig gut.
Ja, ja.
Das könnte ja das offizielle Logo von VS Code Wim von dem Plugin sogar tatsächlich sein.
Oh, stimmt.
Das wäre clever.
Ich habe mir neulich mal wieder Wim mehr eingerichtet und versuche mehr Sachen wieder mit Wim direkt zu machen.
Witzig, ich hatte mit Emacs wieder mehr rumgespielt.
Bis ich gemerkt habe, dass Emacs halt
an sich der geilste Editor ist.
Aber die ganzen
nice kleinen Emacs Keywindings hast du in
macOS überall eh schon in jedem Textfeld.
Und das ist, ja, nee.
Das ist toll.
Emacs ist eigentlich,
was Emacs von den Shortcuts ausmacht, ist eigentlich,
dass die überall sonst auch sind.
Ja.
Emacs ist gut. Emacs hat gewonnen, damals schon.
Nee, du kannst auch eine normale Shell in Linux
auf Wim-Modus umstellen. Schon seit Jahren.
Was? Aber ich finde das
auch verwirrend. Also ich mag auch Wim
Keybindings nur in Editoren,
ehrlich gesagt. Es gibt auch Leute, die benutzen ihren
Firefox mit Wim Shortcuts.
Oder Wimparator
oder Pterodactyl
oder so heißt das.
Nee, mein Gehirn
sagt da, das eine bedient sich so und das andere bedient
sich so. Also wenn ich hacke, wenn ich Code
schreibe, hier bei unserem Pad,
dann ist ganz wichtig, dass da unten Wim
steht, weil wenn ich Code bearbeite,
dann muss ich irgendwie Escape, jjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjjj
Aber überall sonst nicht.
Spannend.
Es gibt auch lange so ein Safari-Plugin
wie Mari.
Das kommt heute jetzt relativ neu raus.
Er hat ja mal vor kurzem wieder so einen Exodus-Moment
gehabt, wo sie, also vor kurzem
ist bestimmt wieder 5-6 Jahre her,
wo sie alle Safari-Plugins beendet haben,
weil es eine neue Extension-API gibt.
Die haben sie jetzt erst fertig gekriegt oder sowas.
Ja, die gibt es jetzt schon irgendwie 3 Jahre gefühlt wieder,
aber es gab halt keine Plugins.
Sie kennen ja jetzt Web-Extensions.
Aber sogar auf iOS.
Und das finde ich halt hart. Aber das nutzt halt keiner.
Also niemand baut das, weil du musst halt immer noch eine App
publishen in den Apple App Store, die
deine Extension bundelt, damit du die da reinkriegst.
Sprich, du brauchst einen Developer Account, sprich, du musst
100 Dollar im Jahr zahlen. Ja, aber du kannst
potenziell eine Extension, die du einmal für
Chrome oder Firefox gebaut hast, einfach
nochmal publishen. Ja, wenn du 100 Dollar im Jahr zahlst.
Du musst es aber nicht komplett von vorne
bauen. Das ist richtig. Also für die
Compatibility ist das mega. Ja, finde ich.
Aber du findest halt die wenigsten Plugins, die wenigsten
Add-ons auch für Safari. Aber was ich halt wirklich
die ich immer noch vermisse, jetzt seit 10 Jahren oder was weiß ich,
ist die Red Enhancement Suit.
Aber irgendwann, irgendwann...
Ach, du sagst auch Suit.
Ah, Suite, verdammt.
Ah, das hat mir mein alter Manager schon mal gesagt gehabt.
Dass es irgendwie so ein deutsches Problem ist,
dass alle Deutschen immer Suit sagen.
Ich zog jedes Mal zusammen auf Arbeit,
wenn die Leute Test-Suite sagen.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe das jetzt von meinen deutschen Kollegen
so häufig gehört, dass ich mir auch nicht mehr ganz sicher bin,
was richtig ist.
Nee, du hast absolut recht, es heißt Suite.
Es heißt Sweet.
Und ich muss mich echt zusammenreißen.
Ich war lange der, der dann auf Arbeit
die Leute korrigiert hat,
wenn sie Wörter falsch ausgesprochen haben.
Ich wollte nicht der Typ sein, der Leute korrigiert,
weil sie Wörter falsch aussprechen.
Aber es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die tun halt weh.
Ich habe vorhin gemeint, die ganzen Kollegen, die mal
Lounge Day sagen und die ganzen Leute in Deutschland.
Früher gab es ja hauptsächlich Leute, die immer von Cocoa
gesprochen haben und nicht Cocoa.
Cocoa-Pots.
Das war bei,
wo wir gerade bei Wordle vorhin waren.
Es gibt ein Spiel, wenn euch Wordle noch zu einfach ist,
spielt Absurdle.
Ich packe den Link in die Schuhe.
Absurdle ist Wordle,
aber halt mit Wörtern,
die mitunter bloß aus zwei unterschiedlichen Buchstaben bestehen.
Oder aus drei unterschiedlichen Buchstaben.
Und du kannst es
coolerweise...
Nee, es müssen schon fünf Buchstaben sein.
Ach, ich hatte zwei Buchstaben.
Ja, aber nur zwei unterschiedliche.
Ach so.
So Wörter wie Q.
Q ist halt echt gewollt.
Und du kannst es, es ist nicht nur
eins pro Tag, du kannst es zehnmal hintereinander spielen,
aber du brauchst halt auch irgendwie
20 Versuche, um ein Wort rauszufinden.
Und einmal hatte ich das Wort Kakao.
Weil das englische
Coco ist ja auch bloß
eine falsche Schreibweise von dem
eigentlichen Wort für Schokolade,
was da lautet Kakao. Das deutsche Kakao
ist eigentlich korrekter als das englische Coco.
Was? Das englische ist
Cocoa, um es mal
abzugrenzen, aber eigentlich ist
das ursprüngliche Wort Kakao.
Mit C.
Aha.
Ich kann ja nicht von Kakaopods
sprechen.
Und das Verhältnis heißt halt nicht
Kakao, das heißt Kaukau.
Ich glaube, die Leute haben es irgendwie im Englischen einfach mal umgedreht, weil es mehr nach
Schoko klingt oder aussieht.
Ja, aber da muss es ja irgendwo, trotz der Begriff,
ich dachte, es ging in die andere Richtung,
die etymologische Abstammung.
Ich habe zu Hause an der Wand bei mir so ein
NATO-Alphabet kleben.
ähm, also dieses
phonetische Alphabet, bloß dass es halt
überall die falschen Begriffe nimmt.
Achso, mit Echo und Whisky.
Ja, und das ist halt, äh, Q steht halt Q
drunter.
Aber das passt ja fast sogar noch.
Aber bei C halt auch C-U-E, auch Q.
Das klingt halt einfach identisch.
Und, äh,
haufenweise Begriffe, wo du halt,
ich glaub, K war Nock.
Achso,
wo du den Begriff gar nicht, wenn du den gar nicht raushörst.
Das ist richtig witzig. Ich finde das großartig.
Ja, kriegen wir noch einen Bogen zu irgendeinem Thema?
Ich bin gespannt.
Achso, wenn wir schon bei winzigen Wordle-Sachen sind.
Wir haben in der Liste noch...
Jetzt frage ich mich, wenn du das schon Absurdel genannt hast,
und das heißt ja auch Wordle und nicht Wordle.
Heißt das jetzt, dass ich dieses Projekt hier Letterle oder Lateral?
Ja, dieses eine, ich hätte es auch anders geschrieben.
Aber Letterle.
Ja, es gibt.
Ich finde, Letterle klingt irgendwie cuter.
Aber er ist halt auch so ein Wordle-Klon,
wo du halt nur einen einzigen Buchstaben
rechnen hast als 26 zur Auswahl.
Das Witzige ist, du kannst denselben Buchstaben auch mehrfach raten.
Dann kannst du mehr als 26 Versuche brauchen,
um den richtigen Buchstaben zu erraten.
Ja, da wäre es geil, wenn du wirklich
jeden Tag nur eins spielen könntest.
Weil dann darfst du jeden Tag einmal
einen Buchstaben raten.
Und dann hast du sechs Versuche und dann ist es vorbei.
Ja, wie bei Wordle.
Ja, aber da hast du halt nicht diesen Mastermind-Aspekt, wo du halt irgendwelche Hinweise hast, das ist purer Zufall.
Oh Mann.
Okay, dann haben wir den ganzen Wordle-Shit durch.
Ja.
Aber du spielst das wirklich jeden Tag?
Naja, das ist so, bevor du ins Bett gehst, jetzt guckst du nochmal rein.
Ach ja, warte, ich spiel nochmal eins.
Vorgestern habe ich mit einem Kumpel zusammen
bis spätabends was gehackt, bis nachts um drei.
Und dann haben wir so festgestellt,
wir müssen aufhören, mein Gehirn ist brei.
Ja, lass uns mal aufhören.
Ich spiele noch ein Wordle.
Sehr schön.
Und dann dachte ich, ja fuck, ich muss noch ein Wordle spielen.
Das Nette ist einfach,
dass du einfach nur jeden Tag ein Spiel spielen kannst.
Du spielst jeden Tag dieses eine Spiel.
Bei dem Official Wordle.
Und jeder hat das gleiche Wort.
Es ist irgendwie, du machst einen neuen Browser auf
und dann kannst du noch eins spielen, sondern es ist einfach
den Tag gibt es das Wort.
Das ist schon cool gemacht eigentlich.
Das war ja ein Ersatz für
ähm
was war, wie war die Backstory?
Der Entwickler davon hat das für seine Frau gemacht,
weil die gerne aus der Zeitung
die
die Spiele gemacht hat.
Crossroads, Crossroads, ja.
Und da hast du ja auch bloß ein Spiel pro Zeitungsausgabe.
Und deswegen passt es irgendwie,
dass das jetzt von der New York Times gekauft wurde.
Oder von der Washington Post.
Die New York Times hat es gekauft.
Und jetzt frage ich mich, was machen die damit?
Die Washington Post hätte es ja nur gekauft, wenn es irgendwie Amazon-kritisch gewesen wäre.
Und dann hätten sie es aufgekauft und irgendwie einen Spin draufgelegt.
Das habe ich jetzt gehört.
In Kopenhagen, Amsterdam, Rotterdam, irgendwo hat sich Jeff Bezos ein Schiff bauen lassen.
Eine Yacht, die 40 Meter hoch ist.
Die größte Privatjacht der Welt.
Natürlich passt sie auch zu seinem Ego.
Ja, und der kriegt die aber nicht aus der Werft raus, weil sie...
unter irgendeiner Brücke nicht durchkommt,
eine historische Brücke, die müssten diese Brücke
abbauen. Eine Brücke, wo sie in den 70ern
versprochen haben, dass die nie wieder mal abgebaut
wird, weil sie damals schon wegen irgendwas abgebaut
haben. Jetzt besticht ja gerade den
lokalen Council, dass die das halt
doch abbauen. Und die haben halt schon eingewilligt
quasi und die Bevölkerung jetzt so, what the fuck?
Ich würde das so feiern, wenn
seitdem das nicht... Ja, vor allem, die können
auch einfach das...
Der Witz war doch einfach nur, dass die den Mittelmasten
irgendwie nicht draufbauen müssen, wenn ich das richtig gelesen
habe. Dann können sie das doch einfach
nicht dort machen. Was ist das fucking Problem?
Ich glaube, achso, weißt du, das ist ein
Segelschiff? Das ist kein Segelschiff, aber die haben
auf jeden Fall irgendeinen größeren Mittelteil, der aber nicht
drauf sein muss. Ja,
würde gerade sagen, weil wenn es ein wirkliches Segelschiff ist, dann
ist das Ding so fest irgendwie. Ja, dann können sie es auch
raus, sie bauen das doch eh neu, dann
schleppt das Teil halt raus und baut es woanders fertig,
wenn ihr wisst, dass das da nicht geht. Was ein dummes
Problem. Ja,
also ich würde das so feiern, wenn sie ihm das einfach,
wenn sie sagen, nö. Bitte nicht.
Fuck you, Bezos.
Ja, aber echt, ey.
Wie kann man so ein Ego haben,
dass man sich schon mit,
dass man sich erstmal mit dem Riesendildo ins All fliegt
und dann da...
Das ist wahrscheinlich, dieser Mast sieht wahrscheinlich auch penisförmig aus.
Wenn ich jetzt mal ein Foto von diesem Bildschiff sehen.
Okay, soviel zum Thema Kapitalismuskritik
im Akronolisierbar-Podcast für diese Folge.
Weißt du noch, vor...
Ich klinge jetzt wie so ein Ultrazeitsprung.
Weißt du noch, vor einer halben Stunde,
wo wir gesagt haben,
Wir brauchen mal wieder mehr Konzept für die Folgen.
Wir brauchen mehr
Vorbereitung. Das sind die Momente,
das sind die Folgen, wo wir Gäste haben und die zu ihren
Themen befragen. Aber ich habe tatsächlich ein Thema, was ich
fortsetzen wollte. Oh, stimmt.
Ich hatte gerade auch voll die gute Überleitung
im Kopf vom Schiff. Und zwar
das Schiff von Bezos.
Da gibt es doch, es gibt diese
philosophische
Metapher, das Schiff von
Theseus.
Ah, witzig. Theseus, Bezos.
Oh Gott.
Aua.
Und die Geschichte ging so,
da war ein
Thesäus, wirklich heißt das so, ja?
Das Ship of Thesis, kenn ich das.
Genau. Also es gibt
einen Kapitän oder einen Räder, der hat ein Schiff,
das bringt er in die Werft und sagt,
mein Schiff, da sind die Planken schon
ein bisschen, mach mir mal
alle Planken neu. Und dann geht
der Schiffbauer hin und macht alle Planken ab und
macht neue Planken ran und der hat
dann quasi, hast du komplett, also
Planken, du tauschst quasi jedes Brett
an dem Schiff aus. Und zum Schluss hast du quasi
das gleiche Schiff,
aber du hast jede Planke einmal ausgetauscht.
Und dann
mit dem Schiff freut er sich und
fährt wieder los und hat
immer noch sein Schiff.
Und der alte Schiffbauer,
der Schiffbauer, der das gemacht hat, der hat nur diese
alten Planken rumliegen und merkt,
sind die ja noch okay?
Kann ich mir auch
ein neues Schiff draus bauen?
Aus den alten Planken, so Secondhand-Planken.
Und dann
er aus den Planken ein neues Schiff.
Dann ist das eigentlich das Schiff,
mit dem der andere vorher gekommen ist,
bloß halt einmal disassembled
und reassembled.
Von James May reassembled.
Sorry, das war eine gute Referenz.
Erzähl weiter.
Du hast quasi dieses Schiff
geklont.
Quasi?
Die philosophische Frage ist,
welches Schiff ist nur welches?
Welches ist nur welches Schiff?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Klar, da haben sich viele Leute Gedanken drüber gemacht,
ob du es jetzt am Ownership festmachst,
welches wirklich einfach Theseus-Schiff ist
oder welches das originale Schiff ist,
wie das definiert ist, aber es ist ein witziges
Gedankenspiel, ein witziges Paradoxon.
Das ist auch das Gedankenspiel, das ich jedes Mal habe, wenn ich Star Trek gucke
und jemand gebeamt wird.
Auf jeden Fall.
Du hast ja deine
Consciousness
wird,
ich denke jedes Mal, wenn ich gebeamt werde,
dann werde ich hier getötet.
Wenn ich gebeamt werden würde,
über dich hier getötet und da drüben einfach kopiert.
Hatten wir schon mal den Film The Prestige
geschaut oder angesprochen?
In etwa so. Also guck dich den Film an.
Wir reden nicht weiter über den Film, aber guck diesen Film
ja so gut und sagbar gut.
Und meine Theorie ist, naja, damit
Beamen funktioniert, muss meine
Consciousness quasi die gesamte Zeit
aktiv bleiben. Also ich muss
merken und fühlen, wie ich
ich muss wirklich diese, manchmal
sieht man das in Star Trek, ich sehe, wie die Welt
dieser Raum um mich sich auflöst und
gleichzeitig so übergefedet wird in den Raum, wo ich
gerade reassembled werde, dann
ist mein Bewusstsein
quasi in diesem anderen
Ich. Wenn ich einfach bloß hier ausgeknipst
und da angeknipst werde, könnte der andere einfach bloß
meine Erinnerung haben.
Der andere hat ja keine Möglichkeit zu wissen, dass er jetzt noch entstanden ist.
Für den ist
das ja ein kontinuierlicher Übergang. Aber dass
du,
dass du gerade weggeknipst wurdest,
kann ja... So, und jetzt grusel ich dich.
Theoretisch könnte dir das gleiche passieren,
wenn du abends ins Bett gehst.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben dasselbe kurz gesagt Video mal geschaut.
Da war genau das Thema über Beaming, über Portals und so weiter.
Und dann kam der witzige Spaßaspekt.
Woher wissen wir, dass wir das nicht im Schlaf auch durchgehen jeden Abend?
Das ist der Grund, warum ich so schlecht schlafe.
So, und das ähnliche Problem gibt es auch mit Code, habe ich den Eindruck.
Wir haben vor ein paar Folgen über Aktoren geredet,
weil ich dieses Konzept so ein bisschen feiere und ein bisschen rumgeschaut habe,
was wäre denn ein schönes Actor-Framework für Rust?
Und ich habe ja diese,
er hat einen akronomisierbar berichtete,
hatte ich eine relativ lange Liste,
die ich mal noch nicht auf GitHub getan habe,
aber das muss ich mal machen.
Unterschiedliche Aktoren-Frameworks.
Und ich habe mit einem rumgespielt,
was ich ganz nett fand,
war super klein,
waren vielleicht 700 Zeilen at the time.
Und von der API fühlt es sich genauso an,
wie das, was ich am liebsten benutzen möchte.
Leider hatte es ein, zwei Bugs.
Kein Problem, mache ich einen Pull-Request auf.
und leider hat es ein, zwei Features nicht gehabt.
Nun habe ich auf dieses Projekt vier oder fünf Pull-Requests aufgemacht.
Der erste wurde noch gemerged und released.
Danach hat der Main-Tainer irgendwie das Interesse an dem Projekt verloren
und reagiert seit einem halben, dreivolliger Jahr nicht mehr auf mich.
Ja, Kacke.
Und jetzt wollte ich es tatsächlich mal irgendwie für was benutzen
und mir war es leid, dass ich den Namen von diesem Ding benutze,
was aber eigentlich auf
Craze.io so veröffentlicht ist, aber nicht
das ist, was ich habe, weil ich in meiner
Cargo-Tommel auf meinen Fork verweise.
Und da heißt es dann genauso.
Also habe ich mir irgendwann gedacht,
schweren Herzens,
nachdem ich dem Typen auch geschrieben hatte,
übrigens, ich würde auch Maintainership für dieses Crate übernehmen,
dann forke ich es jetzt.
Und das war eine schwere
Entscheidung. Ich habe aber, ich muss sagen,
ich fand es ganz lustig, es ist ein Actor-Framework
und ich habe, mir ist
dann doch irgendwann endlich ein witziger Name dafür eingefallen.
Ich habe es Hannibal genannt.
Hannibal Actor.
Du bist so eine Nudel.
Und jetzt habe ich auch das Problem.
Das ist MIT-lizenziert.
Das ist vollkommen okay.
Da steht aber drin irgendwie so eine License-Datei.
Da steht Copyright Mozilla Foundation oder Mozilla Huch drin.
Und das ist für mich so ein Zeichen dafür,
dass der Typ, der das Projekt losgetreten hat,
dass das auch ursprünglich
nur diese
License-Datei da reinkopiert hat.
Wenn ich mal das hier aufmache und auf
License klicke, die Datei wurde von dem
ursprünglichen, mir erinnern, von dem anderen Projekt angelegt.
Da steht Mozilla Foundation, Copyright
2090 drin. Hat er die einfach kopiert von einem anderen
Projekt? Der hat einfach gesagt, ich brauche mal
eine MIT-License-Datei, kopiere ich
mal von irgendwo wahrscheinlich. Oder der hat mal
für Mozilla gearbeitet, ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist natürlich schwer nachvollziehen, was da die Gründe
dahinter sind. Und jetzt
frage ich mich,
Ah.
Also, jetzt frage ich mich,
Mist, okay, ich mache wirklich
deutlich, dass mein Projekt ein Fork von dem
anderen ist. Ich will auch nicht irgendwie
Ownership für die 90% Code
da drin oder 80% Code da drin, die nicht von
mir sind, claimen.
Ich meine, dafür ist ein Open Source
Lizenz ja da. Genau, also ich referenziere hier drin
wirklich, ich mache klar, das ist ein Fork von dem
anderen. Ich kann es jetzt allerdings,
jetzt ist es so,
dass viele Rust-Projekte
dual-licensed sind, MIT und Apache
2. Das kann ich jetzt hier, glaube ich,
nicht mehr machen. Ich kann jetzt nicht hier hingehen
und sagen, ich mache mal noch eine Apache 2 Lizenz
drauf, weil da müsste ich eigentlich so ein Issue aufmachen,
wo ich jeden Contributor, der darin vorkommt,
mentione und wenn der die Checkbox
setzt und drunter einen Kommentar schreibt,
ja, bin ich mit einverstanden, dann könnte ich
es lizenzieren, aber so kann ich das nicht.
Also, ja, wie man
so schön sagt, I'm not a lawyer,
but
Essence, ja, du brauchst irgendwie ein Einverständnis,
behaupte ich auch, dass du das
umlizenzieren darf. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so das grundlegende
Jetzt ist meine Überlegung schon seit einiger Zeit,
naja, ich kann auch einfach
einen kompletten Rewrite machen, dann ist alles meins.
Aber,
jetzt kommen wir
zurück zu dem Schiff von Bezos.
Das Projekt,
diese Hannibal Library, die ich jetzt gepumpt habe,
da ist schon ein Großteil
Rewrites von mir drin.
Die sind jetzt schon anders als
das Originalprojekt.
Aber alles andere,
die 700 Zeilen, die vorher da schon waren, oder die
600 Zeilen davon,
das ist so
trivial,
das ist wirklich bloß Interface, ich würde das
Interface nicht ändern,
ich benutze Standardbibliotheken,
externe Bibliotheken und Standard-Library-Sachen
und wenn ich es jetzt neu schreiben würde,
muss ich sagen, ich bin mit dem,
wieso bin ich eigentlich so zufrieden,
ich würde es nicht groß anders schreiben.
Also das ist dann wieder so ein Problem, wo jemand dann halt von
Derivative Work spricht, oder? Wenn du das neu
schreiben würdest. Du kennst ja das, wie es aktuell aussieht.
Genau, das ist so das Problem, was ich habe.
Selbst wenn ich das aus dem Kopf neu schreiben würde,
würde es trotzdem zu einem Großteil
exakt genauso aussehen.
Ja, aber selbst wenn das halt nur, wie du schon
sagst, triviale Sachen sind und
die Interfaces, die wahrscheinlich
eh halbwegs standardisiert sind.
Ein Anwalt
hält da wahrscheinlich eine andere Meinung zu und das macht es natürlich
sehr schwierig, aber
ich verstehe deine Problematik total.
Das ist echt tricky. Ich würde gerne
eigene Library machen,
aber die wäre wirklich von dieser fast kaum
zu unterscheiden. Also mit meinem momentanen
Mindset, weil ich einfach zufrieden bin
mit dieser Library. Und es hat quasi
jemand diese Arbeit geleistet und die
veröffentlicht und
dann aber irgendwie so in der Verrotten
lassen auf GitHub, weil er nichts
mehr dran macht. Und was mache
ich jetzt als jemand, der sowas
weiter benutzen möchte? Es ist eine recht
kleine Lib, es macht wirklich
nur
Passing. Das ist wirklich klein.
Ich meine,
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die Person kein Problem
damit hätte, wenn du das so weiter führst,
beziehungsweise wenn du das umlizenzierst.
Das Sinnvollste wäre wahrscheinlich
irgendwie versuchen, Kontakt aufzunehmen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht darauf hinauslaufen, dass du eben auf GitHub
mehrfach mentions, sondern dass du dir
eine Person nach meiner E-Mail schreibst und mal schaust,
ob die ansprechbar ist irgendwie.
Das ist jetzt blöd,
wo ich die schon geforkt habe.
Ja, aber so kannst du zumindest auch zeigen
und sagen, hier, schau mal, das habe ich gemacht,
aktuell ist das noch so lizenziert, weil es einfach
vermutlich nach meinem Auffassen des Rechtes
so richtig ist, aber was hältst du
davon, wenn ich das unlizenziere, was hältst du davon,
wenn wir... Naja, es wird noch spannender,
diese Library hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo ich sie übernommen hatte, bereits,
wenn du mich jetzt abziehst,
20 Contributors. Ach, scheiße.
Die alle mal,
das ist so typisch, typisch ein
Projekt auf, auch meine eigenen
Libraries haben mit unter 20 Contributors, weil
alle, die mal sehen, das cool finden,
sagen, oh, ich mach hier mal ein,
ich mache hier mal einen Typo-Fix oder sowas
und zack, hast du 20 Contributor auf der
Library. Muss ich jetzt alle fragen. Ich glaube,
es gab irgendwo, gut, das ist jetzt ein wirklich gefährliches
Halbwissen, ich glaube, es gab irgendwo
quasi eine Art Schwelle, wann jemand
rechtlich als Contributor gesehen
wird. Und das ist bei einem Typo-Fix
noch nicht erreicht, aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt ein sehr gefährliches Halbwissen.
Aber ich meine,
um wirklich sicher zu gehen, müsstest du halt
theoretisch mit 22 Leuten,
21 minus dich, Kontakt
aufnehmen und da halt
das abklären.
Dann hast du selber ein Gefühl von Sicherheit,
ohne mit einem Anwalt gesprochen zu haben.
Was alles ein bisschen lächerlich klingt, weil es wahrscheinlich
eh nie rechtlich relevant wird für sowas hier.
Also nie wird jemand daherkommen und da
irgendwie dir auf den Kopf hauen, aber andererseits willst du halt nicht
die Luka-App sein. Es gibt wahrscheinlich schon tausende
Apps oder tausende Lips,
die einfach eine andere Lipp kopieren und klauen.
Siehe Luca.
Genau, zum Beispiel.
Aber die haben halt auch auf den Deckel
bekommen dafür, weil es halt nicht cool war, was sie gemacht haben.
Aber die sind ja auch Firmen, die sich
Anwalt leisten können und ich bin ein einzelner Typ.
Das ist richtig.
Unter MIT-Lizenz wäre es, glaube ich, so überhaupt kein Problem,
wenn ich das zum Beispiel firmenintern nutze,
wenn ich es einfach firmenintern forke, verändere
und firmenintern weiterentwickle, ohne dass ich es je wieder
publische. Das ist doch wahrscheinlich auch nur kein Problem, weil es keiner mitbekommt, oder?
Nein, laut MIT kannst du es, glaube ich, intern einfach
Die Lizenz kann ich wegwerfen.
Nein, die Lizenz und das Copyright muss bleiben, aber du kannst es halt modifizieren
benutzen und weiterverkaufen.
Modifizieren kannst du ja mit MIT sowieso.
Das muss ja auch nicht für im Intern sein, das kannst du ja auch
extern machen. Genau.
Die Frage ist halt nur,
umlizenzieren ist das tricky und das darfst du ja auch
für im Intern theoretisch nicht, da gibt es halt keines auch mit.
Genau, aber
ich muss es auch nicht unbedingt umlizenzieren,
MIT reicht ja völlig aus, aber ich muss halt diesen Copyright
Header immer mitgeben und dem Copyright
Header steht jetzt halt der ursprüngliche
Ich verstehe nicht, bei Copyright Header
in Quelldeck-Dateien sind auch irgendwie
nur so ein komisches Legal Lease geraffelt,
das meiner Auffassung nach überhaupt keine
Relevanz hat. Also es ist wahrscheinlich hinreichend, wenn da steht,
das ist MIT, fertig, oder?
Ja, aber es gibt
halt, es gibt ja
bei MIT schon irgendwie einen ursprünglichen
Rechteinhaber.
Aber gut, was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Wofür hat man diese Info?
Wer das ursprünglich zensiert hat?
Was bringt einem das? Weil du musst ja,
das ist ja letztendlich bloß, dass du Credit weiterreichst,
oder? Mehr erfordert MIT ja nicht.
Ja, schätze ich.
Aber das ist ja hier wahrscheinlich sogar falsch,
wenn da die Mozilla Foundation genügend steht.
Das ist verbreit.
Also ich bin da in so einer Zwickmühle.
Also ich könnte jetzt auch von vorne eine komplett neue Library bauen,
die dann, wie gesagt...
Ja, aber das ist ja rechtlich auch nicht okay,
wenn das quasi identisch das Gleiche ist.
Das wäre dann, also ich meine, du könntest mir nicht,
ich könnte nicht beweisen, dass ich nicht einfach von links nach rechts
das einmal abkopiert oder rüberkopiert habe oder abgeschrieben habe.
Vor allem, wenn es, also jetzt mal nur
hier den
Worst-Case-Bullshit-Szenario an die Wand gemalt,
wenn jemand halt wirklich nachvollziehen
möchte, weil es irgendwie für dich, du machst in Zukunft
was ganz Dummes und die ganze Welt ist gegen
dich und die wollen dann hier, die stecken
selber Energie rein, was zu finden,
was du falsch gemacht hast, wie bei...
Kompromat. Kompromat, genau, das trifft
richtig gut, weil du hier den
guten Bergstall, deine Doktorarbeit gefälscht
hast oder bagiert hast
und die sehen, dass du diese Library hast mit einer
Lizenz, die dir gehört, aber sie sehen auch, dass du
irgendwann mal diese andere geforkt hast, wo du
kontribuiert hast, also was zeitlich davor liegt, also man
hat ja quasi diesen Paper Trail, um zu
sehen, dass du das schon mal gesehen hast.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du diese Maßstäbe von, der hat mal
was abgeschrieben und nicht referenziert,
wie das bei, was weiß ich,
wer war die letzte Person, die Ärger
gekriegt hat, die
Baerbock, ja, wenn du
den Maßstab bei Softwareentwicklern
ansetzt, wie viele Leute
einfach Zeugs von
Stack Overflow irgendwo
reinpasten, ohne dass
zu referenzieren.
Du könntest quasi sagen,
du verlierst deinen Job und
dein Informatik-Diplom,
weil du mal
Code von Stack Overflow
irgendwo anders hin kopiert hast, ohne die Quelle anzugeben.
I'm safe.
Aber war das nicht vor kurzem irgendwie auch Thema,
wie Lizenzen
bei Stack Overflow-Schnipseln aussehen?
Und wem diese Schnipsel
gehören? Ich bin leider auch kein Experte,
weil ich selten Stack Overflow benutze, aber du musst, glaube ich...
Ich liebe nur selten Stack Overflow.
Du schreibst doch auch Software den ganzen Tag gleich.
Ich bin...
Bitte was?
Ich fand irgendwann Stack Overflow so nervig, dass ich oft gehört habe, es zu benutzen.
Ha.
Witzig.
Aber mir war so, ich habe auch schon Code aus Stack Overflow bei uns
auf Arbeit wiedergefunden und du musst,
so wie ich das verstanden habe, in den Kommentar
ranschreiben, aus welchem Stack Overflow Thread du es kopiert hast.
Gut, das mache ich sowieso immer, damit ich ja in Zukunft
den Kontext nach wieder nachvollziehen kann.
Nach dem Motto, warum zum Geier benutzen wir das irgendwo?
In JavaScript kannst du genauer mit Mathematik,
mit Zahlen rechnen,
wenn du einmal auf eine Float Epsilon addierst,
aus irgendeinem Grund.
Frag mich nicht.
Und da musst du dann den richtigen Stack-Overflow-Thread finden,
um zu verstehen, warum.
Aber um zurück zur eigentlichen Unterhaltung zu kommen.
Beerschef.
Nicht so weit, ich wollte zur Lizenzierungsfrage
zurück.
Wie wir
vorhin gewitzelt haben, wir machen diesen Podcast
seit fünf Jahren, um
unsere Fragen und unser gefährliches
Halbwesen in den ETH rauszublasen,
nur um dann von
unseren netten Freunden Schmidlauch,
Thomas und Stefan
im Chat gesagt zu bekommen, wie die Welt eigentlich
funktioniert.
Jörg nicht vergessen.
Oh Jörg, sorry.
Und noch alle anderen.
Bitte sagt uns was eurer Auffassung ist,
wie das eigentlich in Wahrheit funktioniert.
Ja, habt ihr das schon mal gehabt?
Das würde mich mal echt interessieren.
Wir erklären auch dann für die Leute, die das
in unserem Matrix-Raum nicht mitlesen
in der nächsten Folge, was bei rausgekommen ist.
Das werden wir 100% vergessen.
Also schaut einfach in den Matrix-Raum.
Zumindest mache ich zur Zeit auf Arbeit auch so eine kleine
an so Non-Feature-Freitagen mit einem neuen Kollegen
bei mir im Team.
Wir bauen mal Server-Anwendungen
in Rust.
Und gerade für das, was ich da als nächstes mit ihm gerne machen würde, er ist auch Rust-Beginner und geht da voll mit, bin ich beeindruckt. Da würde ich, glaube ich, total auf dem Zahnfleisch gehen nach zwei Stunden Hendrik über Rust-Revus.
Ich mache das seit fünf Jahren.
Und dann habe ich auch mal gesagt, ich finde, für diese Aufgabe wäre so ein Actor-Konzept ganz sinnvoll.
Wir bauen einen Service, wo Sessions drauflaufen, die live sind und nicht einfach bloß Requests an irgendeine Datenbank und Antworten rausgeben,
sondern das sind Sachen, die laufen und interagieren miteinander.
Und da habe ich gesagt, ich würde vorschlagen, wir nehmen diese Actor-Library.
Und dann habe ich auf Honeyball gezeigt.
Und er guckt sich das an und sagt so,
ich weiß nicht, die hat erst 20 Downloads.
Also sowas
nehme ich normalerweise nicht.
Hype-Driven Development.
Guckst du
bei Libraries, die du verwendest,
darauf, wie viele Downloads dir?
Downloads nicht, weil ich diese Stats meistens nicht habe.
Aber wenn ich halt was sehe mit letzter Commit vor einem Jahr,
drei Stars auf GitHub,
ein Contributor,
lohnt sich das überhaupt, das auch zu probieren?
I don't know.
Da lohnt es sich dann zu gucken,
ist das eine Lizenz,
die ich klonen und forken könnte,
dass ich es einfach selber weiterentwicke.
Da kommt,
war das nicht mal ein Feature,
ich hoffe, ich bringe die Sachen durcheinander,
was du und Gilbert mal
in Cargo mit einbauen wollten,
so ein Lizenz-Check-Things?
Das haben glücklicherweise andere Leute schon zu Ende gemacht.
Das geht einfach
deinen gesamten Dependency-Tree durch
und liest von allen deinen Dependencies
die Lizenzen aus und sagt dir...
Irgendwas inkompatibel ist.
Genau, du kannst sogar, ich sehe das regelmäßig in Projekten oder in Säle sind besser gepflegten Projekten.
Du hast zum Beispiel hier in, ich nehme mal Tokio Exim, das ist ein Webframework, da hast du unten eine Deny.tommel und da stehen zum einen Lizenzen drin, die du nicht benutzen möchtest.
Das warnt bei unlizenzierten Sachen zum Beispiel, bei Copy Left Lizenzen.
Bei Copy Left Lizenzen waren bei Unlicensed
warnen.
Genau, und dann macht es
Exceptions, es erlaubt ISC, ich vergiss immer
was ISC ist, MIT und OpenSSL
Lizenzen. Erlaubt
für diese Dependency.
Das ist quasi,
eigentlich ist es so eine Art
Linterfile.
Und das ist eigentlich
ziemlich cool. Dann könntest du theoretisch
auch sehen, wenn ich
ein Update mache von einer Dependency von
mir und da ist plötzlich eine neue Subdependenz.
Das könnte dir auch passieren.
Ah, da habe ich gar nicht gedacht,
das ist ja nicht nur ursprünglich beim Einbinden.
Ich meine, gut, das könnte auch sich was redenzensieren
plötzlich mit einem Update. Genau.
Ist ein License-Change ein Breaking-Change
nach Semba oder nicht?
Eigentlich ja.
Ist ja kein API-Change an sich.
Ja, aber
Breaking-Change ist schwierig. Eigentlich ist es
ein neues Produkt dann.
Eigentlich ist es ein neues Produkt.
Also rein technisch,
wir haben das Problem bei Husky, das ist so ein Tool,
mit dem du so Git-Hooks
benutzen kannst, was einfach nach
dem Committen oder vorm Committen checkt,
dass du alle Lins
erfüllst und dass deine Commit-Message das richtige
Format hat.
Die haben irgendwann mal gesagt, oh,
wir werden von vielen Leuten benutzt,
wir ändern jetzt mal unsere Lizenz auf
irgendwas Inkompatibles mit Firmen.
Und dann konnten wir es eine Weile nicht updaten
und dann
mussten, und
irgendwann haben sie gesagt, ach nee,
es war uns zu kompliziert, wir machen jetzt wieder BSD-Lizenzen
oder MRT-Lizenzen.
Und da denke ich mir auch,
du kannst ja nicht einfach mittendrin, aber es ist halt,
ich würde es wahrscheinlich,
wenn dann, als Breaking-Change machen, als
Major-Version, weil Major-Version
quasi ein komplett neues
Produkt, eine komplett neue Library,
eine komplett neue Binary ist.
Meinst du?
In Essentia ist es ja nicht, was eine Major-Version-Change
ausdrückt, dass es was Neues ist.
Eine Major-Version heißt, dass es
prinzipiell mit dem alten, komplett kompativen
ist. Ja, das ist komplett, das ist halt inkompatibel,
weil es Breaking Changes gibt, aber klar,
eine Lizenzänderung, so wie
die Go-Leute früher Package
API Breaking Changes gemacht haben,
indem sie einfach, das machst du nicht,
ich weiß nicht, wie es aktuell ist,
das machtest du nicht in deiner Go-Libs und hast einfach
eine neue Lib gepublischt und einen neuen Namen.
Und da ist einfach V2 an den Namen
angehangen, weil es dasselbe Shit ist, nur mit einer
Version, weil die keine fucking Versionierung
hatten. Ja, fuck, go.
Auch irgendwie legitim. Und jetzt fällt
mir ein, welchen NPM-Fucker wir neulich hatten.
der mir vorhin nicht eingefallen ist.
Wollen wir den noch ganz kurz erwähnen.
Na klar.
Und zwar, es ist auch fast wirklich an mir vorbeigegangen.
Unseren Zuhörern ist es vielleicht auch jetzt bewusster als mir gerade.
Und zwar gibt es diese npm-Library, Color.js.
Die printet einfach bloß Farben in deinem Terminal.
Total einfach würde ich es nicht nennen,
weil ich printe mal Farben in einem VT100-Terminal.
das ist wirklich ein bisschen Arbeit.
Da hätte ich gerne eine Folge von
Stylwild dazu,
gar nicht so einfach Podcast. Farben.
Ja.
Farbtheorie allgemein, aber auch so
Computer und Farben. Hörst du uns, Stefan?
Mach das bitte.
Ich glaube, das Äquivalent dazu,
Colors für Ruby,
da ist der
Owner oder Terminal Colors, das heißt
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders, ist der
Maintainer auch ein Kumpel von uns.
Aber jetzt hier reden wir über jemanden, den wir nicht kennen.
Und der Maintainer von dieser Colors.js Library...
Scheiße, sorry, ganz kurz.
Die letzte Folge gar nicht so einfach war, sogar über Farben.
Ein Kessel buntes.
Ach Mensch.
Packen wir in die Show Notes.
Bitte hört euch diesen ausgezeichneten Podcast an.
Zumindest der Maintainer von dieser Colors.js Library hat sich irgendwann gedacht,
ich möchte nicht, dass Leute einfach umsonst meine Library verwenden und damit Geld verdienen.
Und ich habe davon nichts.
Ich glaube, da muss noch mehr gewesen sein.
Ich lege mich jetzt nicht darauf fest, aber angeblich hatte der noch ein bisschen mehr psychologische Probleme.
Lies man zumindest so aus dem Subtext.
Und der hat irgendwann gesagt, ich yank das nicht.
Oder was war bei LeftPad?
Der hat das einfach geyankt.
Aber das durfte man das danach nicht mehr.
Das durfte man danach nicht mehr.
Also bei LeftPad war es, der Maintainer hat es einfach gelöscht und du konntest es nicht mehr runterladen.
weshalb andere Registries gemacht haben.
Bei Cargo oder bei Crates ist es so,
wenn du was yankst, dann darfst von Projekten,
die das bereits, ich weiß nicht, wie sie das machen,
aber dann darfst von Projekten, die das bereits in ihrer Package-Datei
und vielleicht in ihrem Log-File haben,
immer noch weiter runtergeladen werden,
aber es darf nicht von neuen hinzugefügt werden.
Das checkt dann, glaube ich, das Tool beim Runterladen.
Wahrscheinlich nur ein Flag, ob yankt es oder nicht.
Genau. Und es bleibt da.
ähm
der Colors-Typ konnte es also nicht einfach
ausziehen, äh, nicht einfach
jenken, äh, was hat er also stattdessen
gemacht? Er hat es bewusst kaputt gemacht
zum einen hat er, äh, gemacht, dass es
ähm, statt Colors diesen geilen
sag mir mal wie das heißt, Thalgo
dieses Cthulhu, äh
Cometh
diese Gruselschrift, äh, produziert und
was, dass, dass, ich muss sagen, mich würde das auch ein bisschen
gruseln, wenn das auf meiner Konsole plötzlich passieren würde
und ich wüsste nicht warum. Ja, still, dann denkst du erstmal
Das ist so wie, als ob auf deinem
Computerbildschirm was überhaupt nicht passt, plötzlich
Schnee ist so wie auf so einem alten Fernseher.
Hast du dich an diese uralten Windows-Malware
erinnern, wo plötzlich die
Buchstaben auf deinem Monitor runtergefallen sind?
Das wollte ich immer mal bauen mit so einer
Webphysik-Engine.
Ja genau, so ein Output und dann hat er
gleichzeitig noch eine Endlosschleife
eingebaut.
Vielleicht sogar eine Rekursiva, zumindest war irgendwo eine Endlosschleife
dran. Ich packe mal den, einen der
Artikel in die Show Notes.
und das
das kollektiv gekostet hat
die CIs, die weltweit dann
mal weiter liefen
das würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren, ob man das in irgendwelchen
Stromverbrauchs, Rechenzentren
Stromverbrauchsgrafen sieht
bei uns hat es ein paar
Leuten in ein paar
Stunden Arbeit gekostet
weil du musst ja erstmal rausfinden
warum werden unsere Tests jetzt alle rot
warum bleiben
die an dieser Stufe stehen
warum werden keine
Worker in der CI mehr frei?
Und dann musst du dich halt
hinsetzen und bei allen Repos, die das irgendwie
als dritte, vierte, fünfte
Unterabhängigkeit vielleicht mit drin haben,
musst du so eine
Resolution in deine Package-JSON schreiben.
Da schreibst du quasi rein, wenn irgendein Package
diese Unterdependency
benutzt, dann nimm bitte immer
diese Version. Das machen wir normalerweise,
um was zu updaten,
weil du irgendwie eine Dependency hast,
die eine Unterdependency
nicht geupdatet hat und du hast dann irgendeine
Vulnerability drin und das updatest du dann einfach selber,
indem du diese eine Stelle überspringst. Hier mussten wir es machen,
um was zu downgraden.
Auf die Version, die noch nicht kaputt waren.
An dieser Stelle, danke NPM,
aber auf der anderen Seite kann das eigentlich jedem passieren.
Das kann jedem, der externe Dependencies reinzieht, passieren.
Das ist auch kein NPM-Fuckup als solches, aber
die wenigsten NPMs sind irgendwie NPM-Schuld.
Das ist ein Supply Chain
Angriff insofern.
Essentiell. Ich meine, wir haben ja so
ähnliche Sachen schon häufiger gehabt, dass Leute ihre Pakete
verkauft haben und an malicious
actors und die dann halt sparen. Malicious actors
kann man auch für Aktoren
missbrauchen. Witzig.
An Leute halt, die die Schindluder treiben wollten
und die dann halt irgendwie Crypto-Mining
Shit oder einfach Data
Exfiltration Shit mit reingepackt haben in die Package.
Hier ist es halt der Maintainer selbst.
Also muss ja gar nicht mehr verkauft werden, dass das jemand da halt
Scheiße pusht.
euch auch, ich mache einfach eine
Lib, die einfach jeder überall,
ich mache einfach eine Lib, die alle nutzen.
Easy.
Naja, eigentlich relativ einfach, du guckst, welche
neue Programmiersprache oder welches neue Framework
kommt irgendwann raus, zum Beispiel
Swift, und dann
kannst du sagen, was wird
denn jemand in Swift demnächst
bauen, was es in allen anderen Sprachen schon gibt?
Colors zum Beispiel.
Und dann,
also das nächste Colors für die nächste
Programmiersprache könnte auch so ein
sein. Gut, ist halt
bei JavaScript auch so ein Ding, dass es halt gigantisch
ist, das Ecosystem. Und vor allem, dass
JavaScript halt dieses Problem hat, dass Leute halt Packages
für kleinen Scheiß machen.
Gerne. Und
ja, ist halt die Frage,
wie sowas in Zukunft weitergeht. Beziehungsweise
man kann ja nicht wirklich guarden gegen sowas.
Das ist einfach dann, es muss
entweder möglichst groß und bekannt
sein, oder
es geht halt
unter. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und da finde ich das jetzt spannend,
das ist
eher ein Node-Problem.
In JavaScript
im Browser brauchst du keine
Farblibrary auf diese Art und Weise.
Da kannst du tatsächlich Consolog
mit CSS versehen
im Browser.
Und
in
zum Beispiel Dino
würde es auch nochmal anders funktionieren.
Ich habe neulich ein Projekt mit Dino
nochmal gebaut, um mal auszuprobieren.
könnte ich eine Serveranwendung in Dino bauen.
Und da ziehst du deine Standardbibliothek
von einem anderen Server rein.
Aber ich glaube, über Dino machen wir mal eine Extrafolge.
Aber sowas kann dir quasi in jeder Sprache passieren.
Wollte ich das jetzt sagen?
Essentiell ja, klar.
Kann dir in jeder Sprache passieren,
aber in Node ist es halt besonders häufig.
In Node ist es besonders einfach,
weil halt zigtausende Dependencies rumflattern,
gerade durch deinen ganzen Dependency-Tree durch.
Genau, den Punkt wollte ich jetzt ansprechen.
in Dino ziehst du dir auch
externe Dependencies rein und
da hast du dann keine Package-JSON, wo du auf
ein Package in der Registry verweist,
sondern da hast du es teilweise noch viel diverser
oder könntest es viel diverser haben.
Du importierst einfach
Go-Style innerhalb
von deinem Code, import
colors
from https
colors.com slash colors.js
oder so.
Und dann hast du
ich denke mir dann immer, boah, das ist doch eklig,
hast du in jeder Code-Datei
oben irgendwie eine URL stehen.
Das Pattern, was ich dann irgendwie
durchsetzen, ist, dass die Leute alles in einer
Datei importieren und dann von einer Datei
re-exportieren.
Ah, okay.
Aber das zu auditen
macht ja sicherlich auch Spaß.
Das macht sicherlich auch Spaß, das zu auditen.
Ja, wenn wir schon mal mit den Ausbrachen sind, das zu auditen
macht auch Spaß.
Das zu auditieren, heißt das.
Danke, danke.
Aber da ist es bei Dino zumindest so, dass das System
an sich von vornherein wesentlich
restriktiver ist. Bei Node darfst
du von vornherein jede Dependency auf
File System und Network zugreifen und auf
Environment Variables und bei Dino
nicht. Also bei Dino
kannst du es nur granular für deine gesamte
Anwendung einstellen, aber wenn du ein Skript hast,
womit du nur schnell irgendwas
formatieren oder linden möchtest, kannst du definitiv
sagen, du darfst nur auf mein Code Verzeichnis
zugreifen, du darfst meine Environment Variable nicht lesen
und du darfst nicht aufs Network zugreifen.
Das ist immerhin schon mal eine Verbesserung.
dann kannst du dir diese Malware-Typo-Squatting-Angriffe
eventuell verhindern.
Das nächste Problem bei Dino ist,
wenn du dir eine Library reinziehen möchtest,
die nicht auf Dino-Land gehostet ist,
zum Beispiel, das habe ich ausprobiert,
RxJS,
dann ziehst du dir die,
was auch bei JavaScript recht üblich ist,
von irgendeinem CDN runter,
der was für dich rehostet,
zum Beispiel Skypack.
Du möchtest RxJS haben? Gibt's hier auf
NPM. Ist noch kein
ECMAScript-Style-Modul.
Gibt's aber auf Skypack
transpiliert. Musst du einfach bloß importieren
from http skypack.dev
slash RxJS.
Das wird alles so unglaublich fragil.
Und, äh, ja.
Ich bin damit...
Es ist spannend und es ist
interessant und ich find's
irgendwie cool, wie produktiv man damit sein kann,
aber ich hab auch Angst davor, muss ich sagen.
Ja, und dann bauen wir halt mittlerweile
halt Software, die
keine Ahnung,
in was für Kontexten benutzt wird.
Das basiert alles auf diesem
Stack. Geil.
Geil. Ich habe richtig Bock
auf die Zukunft.
Man merkt, dass wir alt werden können.
Mann, nein.
Vielleicht muss ich einfach
die Augen zukneifen und das
akzeptieren. I for one welcome our
new JavaScript overloads.
Ich
Ich klinge jetzt gleich wie ein YouTuber.
Ich schreibe mal bitte in die Kommentare,
wie ihr euch vorstellt,
dass so Supply Chains
organisiert werden sollten. Wie sollten
Package Registries funktionieren oder
wie sollte man Dependencies
verteilen und
reinziehen und
importieren können auf eine Art
und Weise, wo man sich nicht die Haare
rausreißt am Ende des Tages.
Bei NPM sieht man immer wieder, dass es an vielen Stellen
kaputt geht. Auf der anderen Seite
machen es alle anderen Hoster ähnlich wie NPM.
Ja, wir haten immer auf NPM rum,
aber SNC sieht anders mal genauso scheiße aus.
NPM ist bloß
das Ding, was in die Probleme
als erstes reinrennt, weil sie am größten sind.
Ja.
Vielleicht nicht mal als erstes, aber
am öffentlichsten.
Am öffentlichsten, ja.
Also das ist einfach ein einfaches Ziel.
Es gab auch auf PyPy schon viel Bullshit,
der rumgeflattert ist. Python hat ja auch genauso
witziges kaputtes Dependency Management.
Ja.
Dieser alte Bullshit mit der, alte Bullshit,
Da gehen wir noch sehr aktuelle Bullshit mit der Requirements
TXT, wo du halt einfach
Zeile für Zeile das anbindest an PIP-Install,
wenn du PIP-Install-R Requirements TXT
ausführst. Einfach bloß Argumente
für das... Und da könnte halt einfach ein Doppelpunkt
RMRF-Tilde stehen.
Oder bei Swift, wo
deine... Ja, aber das ist
ja immerhin in der Sandbox wird das ausgeführt.
Da kannst du ja nur in Anführungsstrichen
so viel Bullshit machen. Es kann trotzdem Bullshit
machen. Bei Rust hast du Build-RS
Dateien, die andere
Compiler ausführen dürfen. Dann hast du
dass dein Rust-Projekt nicht baut,
weil du CMake nicht installiert hast,
weil das Ding noch irgendeine C++-Bibliothek
kompilieren muss,
während es deine Rust-Bibliothek kompiliert wird.
Genau so sollte die Welt ausschauen.
Genau so sollte die Welt ausschauen, ja.
Was ich nicht gesehen habe,
man könnte tatsächlich Rust und SIG kombinieren,
weil SIG einen eingebauten C-Compiler hat
und dann seine C-Dependencies
für Rust mit SIG kompilieren.
The fuck?
Dann hast du nämlich ein bisschen,
das ist, glaube ich, einfach portabler,
SIG funktioniert auf allen Betriebssystemen
zum Kompilieren gleich und du hast
nicht so Unterschiede zwischen, wo liegen jetzt meine
Header-Dateien, wie du es
bei C++ und C-Projekten hast.
Anyway, wir rennen ganz schön hin und her mit den Themen.
Wir haben jetzt aber auch schon irgendwie
eine Stunde erreicht, zumindest
hier auf meiner Uhr.
Wollen wir das Ganze abrunden
und über die Picks
der Woche reden? Das können
wir gerne tun.
Siehst du, wie ich der Woche gesagt habe?
Ich muss ganz kurz
mal meine Pics noch zusammensammeln.
Okay.
Ich habe nämlich dieses Mal
ein schönes Command-Line-Tool.
Natürlich frisch aus meiner Rust-Blase.
Aber ich finde es total nice.
Und zwar heißt das, du kennst wahrscheinlich
du, D-U. Das ist so ein
Disk-Usage. Das heißt einfach Disk-Usage.
Das ist so ein Disk-Usage-Teil.
So ein Command-Line-Tool, mit dem du einfach gucken kannst,
wie groß ist der Inhalt von diesem Ordner.
Und was benutzt du denn eigentlich
zum Aufräumen,
wenn du jetzt
Zeugs wegschmeißen musst?
Du meinst, wenn ich einen genutzen Platz
finden möchte oder was? Genau.
Dann nutze ich tatsächlich grafische Tools.
Ja, ist ein bisschen angenehmer als irgendwie so ein
Command-Line-Tool, aber weißt du, was
noch besser
ist als Command-Line-Tools
und grafische Tools?
TUI-Tools.
Ja, wollte gerade sagen. Und es gibt dieses schöne
Tool, ich führe es dir mal vor, du kennst
Du, da sagt man meistens Du,
Du-SH,
was einfach alles zusammen hat,
was in diesem Ordner vorkommt. Das ist mein gesamtes Code-Verzeichnis
ein bisschen viel, vielleicht hier irgendwie
einen so einen Unterordner.
Du kannst ja nicht ganz in den armen kleinen Git-Verzeichnissen durchgeben.
So, jetzt sagst du Du-SH
Punkt und dann hast du 700 Megabyte,
ist jetzt dieser Ordner groß. Das gleiche kannst du
mit Dua. Alter, was hast du da drin
in einem so einen Code? Cache.
Dua gibt dir einfach bloß
volle Standardauflistung.
Genau, das ist ein...
Ich sehe, das Target-Verzeichnis ist 739,5 MB
und insgesamt dieses Verzeichnis
ist 739,7 MB.
Lass uns doch mal aufräumen. Und jetzt gibt es
dieses schöne Tool, das heißt DUA
und das ist, wenn ich es einfach so
aufrufe,
sieht es relativ genauso aus wie DUO
mit einer schönen Auflistung.
Deswegen unterscheidet es sich,
es hat einen interaktiven Modus
und da kann ich jetzt
hier so
Explorer-mäßig. Ein bisschen aus wie Ranger.
Oder Midnight Commander oder irgend sowas.
Genau. Und ich kann, ich muss
jedes Mal ein bisschen nochmal nachgucken. Ich drücke einfach
H, ne,
Fragezeichen und dann sehe ich die Shortcuts.
Ich mache mal die Schrift hier einen Tick kleiner,
dass wir auch alles lesen können.
Und ich kann quasi...
Macht sich auch wieder super in dem Audio-Format.
Genau, aber du hast einen Shortcut, mit dem
du was mit D zum Löschen markierst
und dann kannst du weiter rum
browsen oder was anderes zum Löschen markieren.
Ah, steht für Disk Usage Analyzer.
Jetzt ist auch da. Genau. Und ich
markiere jetzt einfach mal drei random Dateien.
Und jetzt ist auf der rechten
Seite ein Panel aufgegangen, wo die alle aufgelistet sind und wie
groß die sind. Jetzt kann ich mit Tab darüber gehen.
Und jetzt sehe ich oben glücklicherweise recht
fett. Ich kann jetzt STRG T
drücken, um die in den Trash zu moven.
Oder ich kann STRG R drücken, um sie komplett zu
löschen. Nice. Und jetzt drücke ich einfach
bei STRG R und die sind alle einfach
verschwunden. Beautiful.
Und der zeigt dir auch schön grafisch an,
welche Dateien oder welche Ordner
in diesem Pfad gerade das fetteste ist.
Uh, das ist für Balken, ja.
Jetzt ist der fetteste Balken des Git-Verzeichnisses.
Vielleicht weg damit.
Mach Marie Kondo-Style weg mit dem Git-Verzeichnis.
Und so kannst du das,
wenn ich das auf dem Root hier anwende,
du, blablabla,
liest dann weichen Zeugs,
mein ganzer Code-Oder ist 26 GB groß,
vielleicht mache ich das nur auf dem
Rust-Verzeichnis.
Hast du nach Sprachen sortiert?
Ja,
meine Ordnerstruktur ist,
in meinem Home liegt ein Ordner
namens Code und da drin liegt ein Ordner
namens Rust und ein Ordner namens
JavaScript.
Ich glaube sogar auch ein Ordner namens Rift.
Witzig. So, und jetzt habe ich hier mein Code
Rust aufgemacht und du siehst, der fetteste
Ordner ist der Ordner namens Hub.
Das ist nämlich der, wo ich alles, was ich von GitHub
klone, einfach hin klone, was nicht mein eigenes
Zeug ist. Und hier drin ist
dieses Projekt das Größte und hier ist der
größte Ordner
das Target-Verzeichnis.
Da kann ich hier wieder rausgehen, in das nächste,
dann markiere ich mir auch das Target und dann
gehe ich in das nächste und markiere ich mir,
hier ist es das
Node-Moduls-Verzeichnis und jetzt habe ich
aus fünf Ordnern Target und Node-Moduls-Verzeichnisse
im Wert von, das zeichnet mir
das hier an, zwei Gigabyte.
Das ist schick. Das ist geil, ne?
Und jetzt gehe ich rüber und sage,
STRG R
und es ist sauber.
Nice. Und das ist ein kleines
Commandland-Tool, was wir dir einfach... Direkt ein bisschen Platz geschaffen.
Genau. Das Fiese
ist leider, dass der Name
DUA, wenn du dir das installierst...
Duolipa, oder?
Es ist ein anderes. Es gibt
noch ein anderes Disk-Usage-Tool, was nicht das
ist, was du aber kriegst, wenn du Cargo
Install DUA sagst. Aber der Name ist schon komplett
direkt überladen, auch semantisch überladen.
Ja, das ist aber auch ein Disk-Usage-Tool.
Steht ja auch für Disk-Usage-Analyze.
Genau. Was ich dir gerade
gezeigt habe, ist DUA
CLI.
Und was ist DUA?
DUA ist dasselbe Tool, bloß
ein ähnliches Tool,
was Disk Usage Analysts macht.
Aber das mit dieser schönen TUI,
das war CLI.
I see.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr ansehnlich.
Müsst ihr euch mal ausprobieren?
Ich mag solche Tools.
Bitte schickt uns eure liebsten
TUI-Tools, die ihr benutzt.
TUI-Tools sind immer toll.
Das T in TUI steht für toll.
Tolle UI.
So, was ist dein Pick?
Mein Pick der Woche ist ein Link,
den mir Vincent's LifeWackX-Ident
letztens geschickt hat.
Und zwar ist das die Python-Communist-Revolution.
A man once said to abolish the classes
or something like that.
Unfortunately, it is impossible to abolish
class in Python without breaking the language.
So we do the next best thing.
We consider that all classes are born equal.
Tatsächlich, wenn du in Python
import communism,
Natürlich kannst du ausführen.
Communism.revolution.globals.
Und dann sind alle Klassen gleich.
Es ist sowohl ein Herrscher als auch ein Kurs.
Dann kannst du nur noch ein Objekt in ein Set oder ein Dick packen,
weil alle Klassen sind gleich.
Ach so, scheiße.
I love it.
Das sind wahrscheinlich auch nur fünf Zeilen Kurs.
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich finde es großartig.
The Python Communist Revolution.
Cool.
Dann habe wenigstens ich was gezeigt, was man benutzen kann.
Zeichen Code. Es printet
auch noch. Gleich mit drin.
Glory Selection has been held with a huge amount of
Participation. 99,3%.
Secretary General of Party.
Wer ist denn der Leader?
Random Choice.
Was macht denn eine Elektion? Oh Gott.
Ich weiß es nicht anzulesen.
Alles ja noch nicht schön. Ich habe gleich den Code
angeschaut.
Du kannst wahrscheinlich auch solche Witzel machen für
Leader Election in Distributed Systems.
Das ist auch einfach der, der schon am längsten
da ist, wird zum neuen Lieder gewählt.
Ich habe das Ding
sogar nicht gelesen.
Well, not all classes are born equal.
It is not possible to do a complete communist revolution
without breaking the language. This is why there are
elites, like the built-ins, which are more equal
than all of the others.
Ah, da hat doch
einer Animal Farm gelesen.
Okay.
I love it.
Ausgezeichnet. Ja, aber das kommt so ein bisschen
gefühlt aus der ESO-Langen-Ecke.
Und Vincent schickt mir
irgendwelche witzigen kleinen ESO-Lanks.
Ich liebe es.
Keep them coming.
Vielen lieben Dank, Vincent.
Ich hoffe, du hörst uns jetzt auch wieder und hast
den Algorithmen
plus Data Structures
equals Programming Podcast bereits
durchgehört. An dieser
Stelle, glaube ich, können wir
doch
beruhigten Herzens die Sendung
abrunden. Ich glaube auch.
Welche Folge haben wir eigentlich heute?
Die 53?
Achso, du meinst ja, wir nähern uns dem Rentenalter.
Ja, es sind noch zwölf Folgen.
Es sind noch, ah nee, es ist ein Jahr hin.
Es sind noch 14 Folgen.
Das ist noch über ein Jahr hin.
Na dann, schicken wir in einem Jahr
akronomisierbar in die Podcast-Rente.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir planen aufzuhören.
Nee, wenn Rentner bist, geht es erst richtig los.
Also das war akronomisierbar Folge 53.
Vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr bis dahin da geblieben seid.
Schreibt uns gerne, joint unseren Matrix-Chat.
Linke ist auf akkonomisier.bar oben in der Leiste.
Korrigiert uns gerne freundlich.
Themenvorschläge sind sehr willkommen.
Und ansonsten, wenn ihr jetzt einfach noch am Spazierengehen seid
oder gerade Sport macht, während ihr diesen Podcast hört
oder euer Bart putzt und ihr noch nicht fertig seid,
keine Sorge, der nächste Podcast in eurem Podcatcher
kommt bereits in 3, 2, 1,